une maman qui prend quelques minutes
pour se rendre compte que sa fille est
bel et bien miss martinique
et puis la complicité l'amour d'une mère
est tellement fort qu'elle ne perd pas
une seconde pour plonger dans les bras
dambre l'étreinte dure quelques minutes
avec quelques petit mot glissé à
l'oreille je me disais mon dieu mais
quel chemin depuis
c'était un trait de dire seigneur te
rends grâce tout cela voilà parce que
j'avoue j'avoue que ma première pensée
quand j'ai vu un homme sur scène jeudi
vont ces faits l'émotion eu tellement
vive est palpable
cambre miss martinique 2010 9 n'arrive
plus à contenir ses larmes
entouré des siens elle réalise que sa
vie va prendre un autre tournant et ses
parents ont tenu à être présents pour
l'occasion
le papa n'est pas encore réalisé parce
que c'est un c'est un conte de fées
la nuit a été très courte mais vous avez
devant vous un papa ravine à partir de
maintenant tout va s'enchaîner pour la
jeune martiniquaise de 21 ans hier
candidate aujourd'hui couronnés elle est
très rapidement plonger dans le
quotidien d'une miss le programme du
jour
cette interview photo comme notre
mission notre objectif est de réussir à
voir une photo qui est la meilleure
valeur et qui justement ne va pas
desservir notre vis sans oublier les
passages télé les questions qu'on pose
habituellement c'est vraiment leur
ressenti par rapport au fait que
l'élection s'était quand même
hier soir c'est encore très frais dans
l'en-tête donc un peu avant leur
ressenti comment ils se sentent pas de
repos prévue pour ambre bosacki dès la
semaine prochaine va rejoindre les
autres miss pour préparer l'élection
nationale